♪ ♪
>> Laura: YOU GET THE SENSE
THAT TWITTER REALLY DIDN’T THINK
IT THROUGH.
NOW, I’M TALKING ABOUT THE
DECISION TO HIT ONE OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S TWEETS WITH AN
ABSURD THAT CHECKED.
IT WAS NOT JUST THAT TWITTER WAS
WRONG ON THE MERITS BUT IT
REBUILT THE STAGGERING HYPOCRISY
OF IT SUPPOSE IT MENTIONED.
NOT ONLY ARE THEY ATTEMPTING TO
EDITORIALIZE IN L SINCE FOR THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES,
THEY DO SO ON ALLOWING CHINESE
PROPAGANDA TO RUN FREE ON
THEIR PLATFORM.
TODAY THE PRESIDENT RESPONDED,
WARNING THAT HE WOULD MOVE TO
REGULATE SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS
THAT TRY TO SILENCE CONSERVATIVE
VOICES.
AND HE PLANS TO SIGN AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER ON THE SUBJECT
TOMORROW.
BUT EVEN BEFORE THAT NEWS,
MISSOURI SENATOR JOSH HAWLEY
CALLED ON THE GOVERNMENT TO
REVOKE LIABILITY PROTECTIONS FOR
SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES WHICH
WOULD DRASTICALLY CHANGE HOW
THEY ARE TREATED.
SENATOR HAWLEY JOINS US
EXCLUSIVELY TONIGHT, SENATOR,
EXPLAIN FOR OUR AUDIENCE HOW
YOUR PROPOSED ACTION WOULD
AFFECT THESE ENTITIES.
>> WELCOME IT WOULD JUST TAKE
AWAY THE SPECIAL DEAL, LAURA
THAT THEY CURRENTLY GET FROM THE
GOVERNMENT.
THERE IS A REASON TWITTER,
FACEBOOK AND GOOGLE HAVE GOTTEN
SO BIG, POWERFUL AND HUGE.
IT IS NOT BECAUSE OF FREE-MARKET
COMPETITION BUT THE LACK OF
FREE-MARKET COMPETITION BECAUSE
THE GOVERNMENT HAS GIVEN THEM A
SPECIAL DEAL THAT FOX NEWS
DOESN’T GET IN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" DOESN’T GET
IT.
NO TRADITIONAL PUBLISHER GETS.
THEY ARE FREE FROM LIABILITY,
FREE FROM SUIT.
THEY HAVE A SPECIAL IMMUNITY.
HERE IS THE THING.
IF THEY ARE GOING TO ACT LIKE
REGULAR PUBLISHERS COMMIT
TWITTER WILL EDITORIALIZE ABOUT
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, THEY OUGHT TO BE
TREATED LIKE A REGULAR PUBLISHER
AND THAT IS WHAT THE BILL WILL D
>> Laura: THERE SEEMS TO BE
SOME OPPOSITION WITHIN THE
SOCIAL MEDIA WORLD TO THAT AS
MARK ZUCKERBERG SPOKE OUT TODAY
AND HE SAID, BASICALLY, THAT IS
NOT WHAT WE DO AT FACEBOOK.
DOES THAT GIVE YOU A SENSE THAT,
WELL, THEY GOT THE MESSAGE
PRETTY QUICKLY IF YOU GO DOWN
THIS ROAD, IT IS GOING TO BE A
ROCKY ONE FOR YOU?
>> I THINK THAT ZUCKERBERG IS
CLEARLY QUITE EAGER TO THROW
TWITTER UNDER THE BUS BECAUSE
ZUCKERBERG DOES NOT WANT TO USE
IMMUNITIES FOR FACEBOOK.
THEY WANT TO KEEP THEIR DEAL.
I’M SURPRISED GOOGLE IS NOT
DOING THE SAME THING.
THE PROBLEM IS GOOGLE HAS BEEN
CENSORING AMERICANS WHO
CRITICIZE THE CHINESE COMMUNIST
PARTY.
SO THESE GUYS REALLY ALL DO THE
STUFF HERE THEY HAVE GOTTEN BY
WITH IT FOR A LONG TIME.
THEY PICKED ON THE PRESIDENT
TWITTER DID THIS TIME AND THAT
IS ELEVATED WHAT THEY ARE DOING.
THEY ARE EDITORIALIZING AND THEY
ARE CENSORING, MAKING POLITICAL
JUDGMENTS AND YET CLAIMING NO,
NO, WE ARE NOT TRADITIONAL
MEDIA.
WE SHOULD BE TREATED DIFFERENT.
WE ARE NEUTRAL.
WE DON’T HAVE OPINIONS BUT JUST
POST OTHER PEOPLES OPINIONS AND
IT JUST ISN’T TRUE, LAURA.
IT IS TIME TO CALL THEM OUT ON
IT.
>> Laura: WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
HEAD OF THE SITE INTEGRITY IT IS
CALLED, THIS GUY WE LOOKED INTO
HIS PAST AND SOME OTHERS.
THIS GUY HAS A HISTORY OF TWEETS
THAT CALLS TRUMP A RACIST
TANGERINE.
JUST RIGHT AFTER THE
INAUGURATION.
HE SAID THERE WERE ACTUAL AND
THE WHITE HOUSE AND IT MIGHT NOT
SURPRISE YOU TO LEARN,
SENATOR HE DONATED TO HILLARY’S
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
HE SAID TWITTER IS WORKING TO
LIMIT THE SPREAD OF POTENTIALLY
HARMFUL AND MISLEADING CONTENT.
SO WHY HAVEN’T HIS TWEETS THEN
COME UP WHY WEREN’T THEY LABELED
AS HARMFUL, PERSONAL ATTACKS?
>> OR HOW ABOUT THE CHINESE
FOREIGN MINISTER OUT THERE ON
TWITTER AND ON SOCIAL MEDIA
SAYING THE UNITED STATES
SHOULDERS ACTUALLY STARTED THE
CORONAVIRUS.
WHO HAVE BEEN OUT THERE SAYING
BEIJING HAS DONE NOTHING WRONG
WITH RELATION TO COVID-19.
THEY TOOK EVERY AVAILABLE AND
JUST OUTRIGHT LIES, FALSEHOODS,
THE INTEGRITY OF THE
UNITED STATES SOLDIERS AS THE
ORIGINATORS OF THE CORONAVIRUS.
TWITTER HASN’T HAD A WORD TO SAY
ABOUT ANY OF THOSE THINGS.
THIS IS A JOKE.
TWITTER SHOWING POLITICAL BIAS.
AGAIN IF THEY WANT TO
EDITORIALIZE LIKE THE NEW YORK
TIME, GO AHEAD, IT IS A FREE
COUNTRY AND A FREE COMPANY BUT
THEY SHOULDN’T GET A SPECIAL
DEAL FROM THE GOVERNMENT BECAUSE
OF IT.
>> Laura: SENATOR, ARE YOU
SHOCKED JUST HOW WILLING SO MANY
IN THE MEDIA ARE TO CARRY THE
WATER OF THE CHINESE COMMUNIST
PARTY WHEN, INDEED HISTORY OF
ABUSE, SUBJUGATION, OPPRESSION,
TORTURE AND POLITICAL
DISSIDENTS.
AND YET TRUMP IS THE PROBLEM ON
THE WORLD STAGE.
ARE YOU SURPRISED BY THIS?
>> I REALLY AM.
PARTICULARLY WHEN YOU SEE WHAT
THEY ARE DOING IN HONG KONG.
YOU CAN SEE THEIR INTENTIONS
LAID BARE.
BEIJING THEY WOULD IMPROVE
DEMOCRACY IN HONG KONG, IMPROVE
IT BY ENDING IT.
AND NOW THEY HAVE THEIR THUMBS
OUT THERE ON THE STREET.
THEY WANT TO STRIP HONG KONG OF
LIBERTIES CHAIT DIMMICK TAKE
AWAY THEIR RIGHT TO ASSEMBLE.
YOU SEE WHAT THEY DID WITH
COVID-19.
RELEASE THIS PANDEMIC ON THE
WORLD BECAUSE TOO INCOMPETENT
AND ALSO FRANKLY TO EVIL TO DEAL
WITH IT.
THEY WOULD NOT ADMIT WHAT THEY
WERE DOING.
AND HEALTH PROBLEMS ON THEIR
HANDS, SUPPRESS THE INFORMATION
AND BECAUSE AT THIS, ALLOW TO
SPREAD INTO A GLOBAL PANDEMIC.
SO THEY HAVE, THEY ARE
RESPONSIBLE, LAURA FOR ALL KINDS
OF WRONGDOINGS AND YET, YOU SEE
THE MEDIA GIVING THEM LIKE
TWITTER, GIVING THEM A FREE PASS
WHILE THEY FOCUS ON THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
IT’S CRAZY.
>> Laura: SENATOR WE CAN’T